[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وبينما نتحدث الان تتفاعل
احداث وتقع اخرى ونبدا من نيويورك وهناك
مثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
امام القضاء مجددا بتهم الاحتيال التي
وصفها بانها محزنه
[موسيقى]
هذه الصور مباشره من موسكو وهناك الخلل
كريم لان الغرب سيصاب بالارهاق بشكل
متزايد من تقديم الدعم الاوكرانيه البيت
الابيض رد بالقول اذا كان بوتين يعتقد انه
يستطيع الصمود اكثر منا فهو مخطئ
وهذه طهران وهناك الغي اليوم الغيت مباراه
سيبهان الايراني والاتحاد السعودي في دوري
ابطال اسيا بسبب ما سماها الاتحاد الاسيوي
لكره القدم ظروفا غير متوقعه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
نحو 10500 مستوطن ومتطرف يهودي يقتحمون
باحات الاقصى
شرطه الاحتلال تعتدي على المرابطين وتعتقل
عددا منهم والخارجيه الفلسطينيه تحذر من
محاولات فرض وقائع جديده على الاقصى وحماس
تدعو للرد على جرائم الاحتلال
في لقاء يعقد للمره الاولى خارج حدوده
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي يجتمعون
فيكييف وسط خلافات حول دعم اوكرانيا
والكرملين يقول ان الغرب سيتعب من دعم
كييف بمرور الوقت والبيت الابيض يقول ان
بوتين مخطئ اذا كان يراهن على ذلك
وسط توتر متصاعد بين بشتينا
وبلغراده بالتخطيط لضم المنطقه الشماليه
وصربيا تعلن خفض القوات قرب حدود كوسوفو
بعد تحذير من واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي
يلوح بعقوبات على صربيا
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
القضاء مجددا بتهمه الاحتيال والمدعيات
العامه تقول انه جنى اكثر من مليار دولار
من خلال الكذب يقول ان القضيه عمليه
احتيال لمنعه من خوض الانتخابات
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم مسارات
مسؤول الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق السابق
دونالد ترامب امام محكمه الفنيونك بتهم
الاحتيال والتظليل بشان ثروته والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي في رايكم ما هي ابرز
التداعيات المحتمله لمحاكمه ترامب بتهمه
الاحتيال والتضليل بشان ثروته جاءت الردود
كالتالي عشره بالمئه توقعوا تداعيات
اقتصاديه تتعلق بامبراطوريه ترامب للاعمال
والعقارات ثمانيه واربعون بالمئه راوا ان
للقضيه تداعيات سياسيه تتعلق بحمله ترامب
في سباق انتخابات الرئاسه بينما قال 42%
انه لا تداعيات سلبيه على وحملته وان
الرئيس السابق سوف يغتنب المحاكمه لصالح
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
افتتاح اكسبو الدوحه 2023 وفي اجندته
ابتكاره حلول عالميه للتصحر ورؤيه قطريه
للتنميه المستدامه
[موسيقى]
قالت دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه ان نحو
10500 مستوطن ومتطرف يهودي اقتحبوا المسجد
الاقصى المبارك في ثالث ايام عيد العرش
اليهودي بحمايه امنيه مشدده من سلطات
الاحتلال وفرضت شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قيودا على دخول المصلين الى المسجد الاقصى
كما اعتقل الثلاثه مرابطين بعد الاعتداء
عليهم في منطقه باب السلسله وابعدت مصلين
اخرين عن المنطقه
ان للمسجد الاقصى فالمصلون الفلسطينيون
يمنعون من الدخول خلال فتره الاقتحامات
قله من كبار السن سمح لهم بالدخول بينما
تجول المستوطنون كبارا وصغارا في باحات
المسجد هكذا يفرض الاحتلال قوانينه على
الارض ومنها ما يمنع حتى صوت الاحتجاج
ابواب المسجد حيث اقرب نقطه يستطيع
المرابطون الفلسطينيون الوصول اليها
تعرضوا للاعتداء من المستوطنين ومن شرطه
الاحتلال التي اعتقلت عددا منهم وابعدت
اخرين عن المنطقه بالكامل وعشرات الالاف
لقلب الواد احتلوا البلد من جديد عشرات
الالاف الله اعلم منين جايبينهم واحنا سته
سبعه ممنوع نقعد هنا في باب السلسله
[موسيقى]
ملاحقه لم يسلم منها الصحفيون الفلسطينيون
اذا نمنع كليا من الاقتراب الى منطقه باب
السلسله من قبل جنود وشرطه الاحتلال دون
اي سبب رغم ان فتره الاقتحامات قد انتهت
الا ان شرطه الاحتلال ما زال تمنع ما زالت
تمنعنا من التواجد في منطقه باب السلسله
هذا تكرر عده مرات هذا اليوم تمت محاصره
وملاحقه الصحفيين الفلسطينيين اوكي خلاص
في المقابل تجول الاف مستوطنين في ازقه
البلده القديمه وادوا طقوسا تلموديه ايضا
عند عتبات المسجد الاقصى هناك قبض امنيه
حديديه في محيط المسجد الاقصى وفي داخل
المسجد الاقصى هذا ادى الى ان يقوم مجلس
الاوقاف بمناشده الى العالم الاسلامي والى
الامه العربيه والاسلاميه ان يتحركوا فعلا
لانقاذ المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ولتامين اقتحاماتهم وتجوالهم عززت شرطه
الاحتلال قواتها ونشرت مئات من عناصرها في
البلده القديمه ومحيطها مشهد وصفه
الفلسطينيون اليوم بهيمنه المستوطنين على
ازقه البلده القديمه وحصار المسجد الاقصى
نجوان سمري الجزيره القدس المحتله
ايهاب جبارين الباحث المختص بالشان
الاسرائيلي استاذ ذهاب غير مره تحدثنا عما
تسعى سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للتحقيق
في المسجد الاقصى وهو التقسيم الزماني
والمكان وتكريس ذلك ما الذي تم تكريسه حتى
الان وما الذي بقي
نعم تحياتي مساء الخير هذه المحاولات هي
تكرار لمحاولات يعني على عده عقود ولا عده
محطات اتت يعني في ظل منذ عام 67 حتى هذه
اللحظه واظن ان هذه هي النقطه المحوريه في
نهايه المطاف منذ عام 67 نوع نتحدث ان
الجزئيه الاولى التي يجب ان نقف عندها في
نهايه المطاف هي عام 72 عندما تمت
التقسيم المكاني والزماني للحرم
الابراهيمي كتجربه باعتقادي لما يمكن ان
يكون عليه تداعياته على الحرم القدس
الشريف وبالتالي كذلك عام 90 عندما تم
هنالك مجزره
الاقصى وكذلك محطات اخرى
96 في كل ظل هذه المحطات التي تتالت بشكل
مستمر يمكن القول ان في كل مره كانت
السلطات الاسرائيليه تحاول ان تضع بصمتها
بشكل اخر وتغير الوضع القائم المتواضع
عليها الان في ظل هذه الحكومه تحديدا هنا
يجب ان نتذكر اننا نحن نتحدث عن حكومه
مربوطه ومرهونه بشكل كبير
باحزاب تنتمي الى الصهيونيه الدينيه والتي
تعلم جيدا هذه الصهيونيه الدينيه تعلم
جيدا انها موجوده في شباك زمني قد يكون
قصير وبالتالي الحرب التي تضيرها اليمين
الاسرائيلي امام
اليسار الاسرائيلي او امام المركز لها
الكثير من التداعيات على امور اخرى في ظل
ان يعني هنالك نوع من الالهاء وهنالك نوع
من
الاسرائيلي الى كل ما يخص اشكاليه
الديمقراطيه ومال الديمقراطيه والتغيير
على ارض الواقع في كل ما يخص الضفه
وتحديدا القدس مستمر بشكل
رهيب واكبر سؤالا حول ما هو هدف بعيد
الامد تسعى اليه كل الحكومات الاسرائيليه
وبين ما هو هدف قصير الاجل ضيق
ومحكوم بالمصلحه الانيه فما هو الهدف بعيد
الامد وما هو الهدف القصير الان
يعني اذا بدانا نتحدث عن قصير الامد في
نهايه المطاف باعتقادها ان اسرائيل تحاول
ان تشكل نوع من الطوق الامني كما فعلته في
جنوب لبنان على سبيل المثال حول منطقه
الحرم القدسي الشريف في كل ما يخص اشكاليه
الاعياد او غيرها من مناسبات دينيه لكي
يكون في هنالك بعض
الطقوس التلميذيه نرى ذلك في سوق
القطانيين نرى ذلك في باب السلسله وفي
غيرها من المناطق الاخرى وتحديدا تحاول
كذلك التجاوز والسيطره على مواقع تخوم
كذلك من الجهه الشرقيه كباب الرحمه ومقبره
الرحمه الاسلاميه في ظل كل ذلك هي في
المدى القصير هي تريد ان تشكل نوع من
التخوم ونوع من الاشكاليات والضم لمناطق
محيطه بالحرم القدسي الشريف على المدى
البعيد بدون ان شك ان المسير يسير بشكل
متسارع نحو تقسيم زماني ومكاني على ارض
الواقع في كل ما يخص الحرم القدسي الشريف
ويجب ان نتذكر ان كل ذلك ان هذا
الاقتحامات لا تمر مرور القراءه الكرام في
نهايه المطاف القدس وتحديدا حرم القدس
الشريف هو مشروع سياده اي بكلمات اخرى
اسرائيل لن تشعر انها موجوده في حاله
سياده اذا لطلب لم تبسط سيطرتها على الحرم
القدس الشريف وتحديدا في ظل هذه الحكومه
اليمينيه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا لايهاب جبارين
الكاتب المختص بالشؤون الاسرائيليه ضيفنا
من تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا وقال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوست بوريل ان
الاتحاد سيقدم تسهيلات ماليه لاوكرانيا
بقيمه خمسه مليارات يورو في الفتره
المقبله اضاف بوريل خلال اجتماع عقده
وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيون في كييف قال ان
القوه ان اقوى التزام الامني يمكن تقديمه
الكيف هو منحها العضويه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقال الرئيس
تعول على تقييم ايجابي من المفوضات
الاوروبيه لبدء مفاوضات انضمامها للاتحاد
بحلول نهايه العام الجاري
ما ترونه هو الاستثناء في دوله غير عضو في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجتمع وزراء خارجيه
التكتل جاؤوا الى اوكرانيا لاجلها في خطوه
تاريخيه بدت بالغه الدلاله مستقبل كييف في
الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول ممثل السياسه
الخارجيه للاتحاد جوزيف بوريل يقترح الرجل
تقديم حزمه تسهيلات ماليه
بقيمه خمسه مليارات يورو ويريد
التزاما اقواه
بالتاكيد اقوى الالتزامات الامنيه التي
يمكننا تقديمها لاوكرانيا هي عضويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا اقوى التزام امني
لاوكرانيا الان اوكرانيا دوله مرشحه
للعضويه وهي تمضي الى ما ابعد من ذلك في
هذا الطريق
اذا كان تاكيد مواصله الدعم الغربي
للاوكرانيين الرساله الابرز للاجتماع
الوزاري الاوروبي فانه ليس من مد من فهم
السياق والتوقيت واضح ان اعباء الحرب تثقل
كواهل الحلفاء
لن تعدم في الصف الاوروبي اصواتا متذمره
من قتال يستنزف الجهد والمال
هذه سلوفاكيا المندفعه يسارا الفائز في
انتخاباتها التشريعيه المبكره له مقاربه
مختلفه لدعم اوكرانيا انه حزب الديمقراطيه
الاجتماعيه بقياده رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
روبرت فيكو المتجه لتشكيل حكومه ائتلافيه
يريد الحزب وقف المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا وينتقد الاتحاد الاوروبي ويعارض
مساعي كييف للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
يدعو الحزب في المقابل الى تحسين العلاقات
مع روسيا تماشيا مع المزاج العام للشعب
سلوفاكي
المزاج المتغير في الجوال الاوكراني تجسده
ايضا بولندا رئيس وزرائها قال ان بلاده
ستوقف دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا لصالح تعزيز
قوتها الدفاعيه هو التحول الوشيك اذا في
السياسات الخارجيه والامنيه لكل من
براتيسلافا ووارثو قبل هذه وتلك ثم تاء
واشنطن الداعم القادم من بعيد حتى
المساعده الامريكيه لاوكرانيا صار يلفها
الغموض يقول رئيس الامريكي انه لا يمكن
السماح بقطع الدعم عن الاوكرانيين ومع ذلك
اغفل الكونغرس المساعدات الماليه تاليف في
مشروع قانون الميزانيه المؤقت الذي اقره
لتجنب اغلاق حكومي في ذلك وغيره اشارات
تتلقفها موسكو يقول الكرملين انما وصفه
بتعب الغرب من تمويل كييف سيزداد وانه
سيؤدي الى تفكك النخب السي اسيه وانقسام
الراي العام الغربي اوكرانيا
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن بروكسل مايكل
السفير السابق للاتحاد الاوروبيه في موسكو
وكبير الباحثين في مركز دراسات السياسه
الاوروبيه ابدا بدميتري بابتش من موسكو ما
مدى واقعيه تعويل الكرملين على تراخي
الضغط الدعم الغربي لكييف وايضا تاكل هذا
التحالف وهذا التصميم الغربي على دعم كييف
الى اي مدى يعول او ما مدى واقعيه هذا
التعويل من الكلام ده على ذلك
في الحقيقه اعتقد اننا لا نتحدث في هذا
المجال على ان السياسيين في الغرب
تعبوهم لا يتعبون لجهه دعم النظامي في
كييف الذي اتى في العام 2014 بعد الاطاحه
برئيس المنتخب ديمقراطيا المشكله في
الحقيقه هي التكاليف الباهظه لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده دعونا نذكر ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تنظر في
امكانيه دفع 24 مليار دولار امريكي لصالح
نظام الرئيس زينينسكي وطبعا مع الانتخابات
في سلوفاكيا لا ارى ان روسيا تعلق امال
كثيره عليها ولكنها من بين المؤشرات بان
الناس لا يودون ان ينفقوا الاموال والوقت
والاسلحه على نظام الرئيس او السيد
زينينسكي في الحقيقه ان حزب الرئيس السابق
او رئيس مجلس الوزراء السابق لسلوفاكيا
الذي يعارض بشكل جذري ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا ان النتائج تشير وتتحدث بالنيابه
عن نفسها ولكن طبعا هذا لا يعني ان حزبه
يدعم روسيا او
التودايا الحرب في اوكرانيا سوف تستمر
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لاوكرانيا حتى
ولو اصبح رئيس مجلس الوزراء واوضح ذلك
ولكنه لا يود ان يرسل الاسلحه الى منطقه
نزاع واعتقد ان هذا التصريح وهذه السياسات
هي السياسات اخلاقيه شرعيه اللا يصب الزيت
على النار لانها تقوم به الدول الغربيه هو
ذلك بالتحديد
ضيفنا من بروكس لسيد مايكل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعقد اجتماعي لوزراء
خرجته لاول مره خارج اراضي الاتحاد ولاول
مره في منطقه حرب هل هذه هي رساله كافيه
هل يمكن ان
تكون اشاره تضامن تخفي الكثير من الخلافات
هل هل هذا ينهي الخلافات الاوروبيه بشان
دعم اوكرانيا
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه الكريمه
تعرفون ان
وزراء السبعه وعشرين اجتمعوا
وكما اعلن السيد بورال هذه مبادره غير
مسبوقه ونتحدث هنا عن رمز او عن مبادره
رمزيه
لدعم اوكرانيا ونظامي الرئيس الينسكي ولكن
بالنسبه الى الانتخابات في السلوفاكيا لن
اغوصا في الحديث عن هذا الموضوع كما فعل
الضيف الاخر بالنسبه الى رمزيه هذا
الاجتماع هو يشير الى دعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي بشكل عارم لاوكرانيا وطبعا
الاجابه سوف نحصل عليها من خلال
ملموسه وعمليه هناك مقترح يقضي بتقديم
المساعدات الاقتصاديه بقيمه 50 مليار
دولار على مدى سنوات لاوكرانيا وما من
وزير خارجيه اوروبيه عارض هذا المقترح
وعلى الارجح سوف يوافق عليه كيف نفهم هذه
الخلافات يعني دعني اتوقف معك قليلا
السيده نريد ان نفهم لانه بولندا قالت لن
تدعم عسكريا هنالك مشكله في الدعم العسكري
المؤقتا في الولايات المتحده بعد عدم
تضمين المسارات لاوكرانيا في الميزانيه
المؤقته هنالك سلوفاكيا هنالك دعوه رفعتها
ايضا اوكرانيا على كل من المجر وسلوفاكيا
وبولندا لانها حضرت الوارده الزراعيه من
اوكرانيا الى دولها حفاظا على مصالح
مزارعها وهذه الدول كلها مقدمه على
انتخابات كيف نفهم وج ود هذه الخلافات مع
استمرار الدعم الغربي
يمكننا ان نفهم هذه
الاختلافات لاننا نتحدث عن بلدان متعدده
تشكل الاتحاد الاوروبي في سلوفاكيا رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الجديد على الارجح يقول
بالتحديد انه لا يود ان يزود اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ولكنه على استعداد لتقديم
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمساعدات الاقتصاديه
لاوكرانيا وهو يوافق على ذلك اذا بالنسبه
الى مواقف
السياسيين الشعبوين ربما هناك ضغط على
السياسيين في بعض البلدان الاوروبيه لكي
يتصرفوا
بطريقه معينه
التركيز اليوم هو على تقديم الدعم لاو
وهذا لم يتغير وهنا اسال ضيفي من موسكو
السيد لم يتغير يعني لم يتوقف الدعم
الغربي لحظه سواء جاء من بولندا او جاء من
غير بولندا حتى لو كانت هنالك تحفظات لدى
بعض الدول فانه الشاهد منذ بدات هذه الحرب
ان الدعم الغربي لم يتوقف فماذا يقصد
السيد بيسكوف بان الدعم سيتاكل وان الغرب
سيتعب لم يتعب حتى الان
في الحقيقه يمكنني ان اقول انه وما لدينا
في الغرب هو
مواجهه بين الايديولوجيه والبراجماتيه
هناك
الايدولوجيه الليبراليه ولسوء الحظ هي
المهيمنه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والديمقراطيات
والاداره الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان
تدعو الى عدم تقديم التنازلات مع روسيا
والى استمرار الضغط على روسيا وتدعو ايضا
الى دعم اوكرانيا من خلال تزويدها بشتى
انواع الاسلحه ولكن في الوقت نفسه في
اوروبا هناك عدد من السياسيين
الذين يعارضون هذه الامور بالاضافه الى
الواردات الزراعيه حتى من اوكرانيا لحمايه
المزارعين الداخليين وطبعا في العام 2014
بعد تغيير نظام بالقوه في اوكرانيا ان
اوروبا
اتخذت قرارا مرتبطا
بالحبوب الاوكرانيه نشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
موسكو السيد متر المحلل السياسيه ونشت
ضيفنا للاسف الوقت من بروكسل
السفر السابق للاتحاد الاوروبي في موسكو
اتهمت سلوفاكيا روسيا بالتدخل في
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي جرت السبت
الماضي واستدعت مسؤولا بالسفاره الروسيه
ودعت موسكو الى وقف ما وصفتها بانشطه
التضليل التي تستهدف سلوفاكيا اما السفاره
الروسيه في سلوفاكيا فقالت انها ترفض بشده
ما وصفتها بالادعاءات الزائفه بشان التدخل
المزعوم في الانتخابات اسلوبكيه
الحزب الذي تقدم في انتخاباته سلوفاكيا
وابرز مواقفه نتابعها في هذا العرض
اسس حزب السمير اس دي الذي تصدر
الانتخابات العامه في سلوفاكيا عام
1999 على يد رئيس الوزراء السابق روبرت
فيكو الذي لا يزال على راس قيادته حتى
الان يعد الحزب الذي يعني اسمه الاتجاه
الديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه حزبا اشتراكيا
شعبويا وخرج من رحم حزب اليسار الديمقراطي
في مرحله ما بعد الشيوعيه اعتمد في دعايته
الانتخابيه على قضيه الدعم العسكري
المقدمي الى اوكرانيا اذ تعهد زعيمه فيكو
بان سلوفاكيا لن ترسل قطعه ذخيره واحده
الى كييف ورغم ان حزب السمير اس دي يؤكد
دعمه لعضويه بلاده في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والنيتو لكنه غالبا ما يطرح مواقف مؤيده
لروسيا ومشككه في السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ومعاديه لوشن سبق للحزب
الهيمنه على الساحه السياسيه في سلوفاكيا
حيث قاد حكومتين ائتلافيتين بين عامي 2006
و2010 ولاحقا بين 2012
وثمانيه عشر في عام 2018 اضطر رئيس الحزب
روبرت فيكو الى التنحي عن رئاسه الحكومه
بعد احتجاجات على مقتل صحفي استقصائي يدعى
وخطيبته بعد كشفه عن علاقه قال انها تربط
بين المافيا الايطاليه وفيكو
[موسيقى]
الى كوسوفو وقال رئيس الوزراء البن كوتي
ان الصرب الذين اشتبكوا مع قوات الامن
الكوسوفيه الاسبوع الماضي تدربوا في قاعده
للجيش الصربي قبل اربعه ايام من تنفيذ
الهجوم ونشر كورتي صورا قال انها تظهر
تدريبات للمجموعه المهاجمه في قواعد
عسكريه صربيه واتهم بلغراد بالتخطيط ودعم
الهجمات وقال المسؤول الكوسوفي ان الهجوم
كان جزءا من خطه اكبر لضم الشمال كوسوفو
الى صربيا من خلال مهاجمه 37 موقعا ثم
انشاء ممر الى صربيا لتمكينها من الامداد
بالاسلحه والقوات
وبعد تحذير واشنطن من انتشار عسكري صربيا
كبير على طول الحدود مع كوسوفو قال قائد
الجيش الصربي النصربي سحبت بعد قوتها
المتمركزه بالقرب من الحدود مع الكوسوفو
وفي الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع
انه اذا تلقى الجيش الصربي امرا من الرئيس
بالهجوم على كوسوفو فانه سينفذ هذه المهمه
بكفاءه ومهنيه ونجاح وفق تعبيره وخلال
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس الاركان العامه
في بلغراد رفض بوتش بيتشر اتهام بلاده
بالتخطيط لضم اراضي كوسوفو الشماليه
ومن ناحيه الثانيه اعلن حلف الشمال
الاطلسي انه سينشر نحو 600 جنديا بريطاني
في كوسوفو لتعزيز قوته المنتشره في البلاد
باسم قوه
وقال المتحدث باسم
ان المملكه المتحده بصدد نشر نحو 200 جندي
للانضمام الى وحده بريطانيه قوامها 400
جنديه يتدربون حاليا في كوسوفو على ان
تعقب ذلك تعزيزات اضافيه من حلفاء اخرين
وفق تعبيره
وقال المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
سيكون هناك قرار من الدول الاعضاء في
الوقت المناسب بشان كيفيه رد الاتحاد على
ما جرى في كوسوفو في الرابع والعشرين من
سبتمبر ولوحا باستعداد الاتحاد لفرد
عقوبات على صربيا اذا تبين تورطها في
الهجوم واضاف المتحدث ان الشرطه كوسوفو
على تواصل مع بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي
لتوضيح ملابسات ما جرى والمسؤولين عن هذا
الهجوم
هذا وتعيش الحدود بين كوسوفو وصربيا على
واقع مواجهات متكرره بين مجموعات صربيه
وشرطه كوسوفو منذ نحو اسبوع محمد البقالي
كان هناك في جوله لاطلاعنا على المشهد
اجواء التوتر في هذه المنطقه الحدوديه بين
صربيا وكوسوفو لا تخطئها العين بعد عشره
ايام من المواجهات التي وقعت بين مجموعه
صربيه هو عناصر الشرطه ما زالت القوات
الخاصه لكوسوفو تنتشر في المكان والمخاوف
ما زالت كبيره من تطور الوضع الى مواجهات
بين البلدين
كيف تطورت الامور الى هذا الحد في هذا
المكان بالضبط هجمت مجموعه صربيه مشكله من
30 شخصا عناصر الشرطه قال نحو عشره ايام
هذه بعض من اثار هذا الهجوم
المجموعه اعتصمت عندما تدخلت عناصر القوات
الخاصه بهذا الجبل حيث يوجد دير ارثوذكسي
هناك
هذا المشهد يفسر جزءا من طبيعه هذا التوتر
نحن هنا على ارض كوسوفو لكن العلامه
المرفوع هو علم صربيا لماذا لان هنا تعيش
اقليه صربيه قوامها 100 الفين او يزيدون
لا يخفون ولائهم لصربيا
القصه اكثر يجب العوده الى تسعينيات القرن
الماضي حينما خاضت كوسوفو حربا دروسا
للحصول على استقلالها عن صربيا اعلن عنه
عام 2008 لم تعترف صربيا ابدا باستقلال
كوسوفو وبقيت الاقليات الصربيه تعيش في
مدن شمال البلاد هكذا تعيش كوسوفو ما يشبه
اجواء حرب لم تندلع فالمخاوف هنا كبيره من
اقدام صربيا على ضم الاقليم الشمالي
بضريعه وجودها اقليه صربيه فيه لذلك رغم
ان المواجهات كانت محدوده في الزمن
والمكان فقد استنفرت العالم لقد بدات اشبه
ما تكون بنذر حرب قد تشتعل في كل لحظه ما
لم تطفئ شرارتها قبل تمددها محمد البقالي
الجزيره بريستينا
وينضم الينا من روما جورجيو فوتشين شيوني
الباحث المختص في شؤون البلقان في المعهد
الايطالي للدراسات السياسيه
والدوليه هل هنالك فرصه
او ما هي الفرصه فرصه ان يبقى صرب كوسوفو
داخل كوسه ويندمجون في بقيه العرقيه
الالبانيه التي تسكن هذا الاقليم
في الجنوب فهم يندمجون بشكل اكبر في
المؤسسات في كوسوفو وهم يعيشون في هذه
الظروف منذ سنوات طويله ولذلك هم جزء من
النسيج المجتمعي الكوسوفي ومن المؤسسات في
كوسوفو ولذلك هناك تمييز بين هؤلاء وهؤلاء
الذين يعيشون في الشمال من حيث محاوله
بلغراد السيطره على صرب كوسوفو اذا هذه
المساله في هذه المرحله يعني حاولت من قبل
ربما السيطره على الاقليم كله ولم تفلح
بسبب عوامل خارجيه دعم النيتو ودعم
الولايات المتحده دعم الاوروبيين لكن ما
هي العوامل الان التي تمنع بالجراد من
محاوله ضم القسم الشمالي من كورسو
في الحقيقه يجب ان نعرف انه في كوسوفو
هناك اكبر
بعثه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في العالم وهو سوف
تصبح وهي سوف تصبح اكبر بعد لان المملكه
المتحده سوف ترسل قواتا اضافيه والمانيا
تنظر في امكانيه ارسال المزيد من الجنود
كجزء من بعثه النيتو هذه وبالتالي بالنسبه
الى صربيا هذه مواجهه دبلوماسيه واقتصاديه
وعسكريه تعتبر بالعمليه الانتحاريه اذا ما
حاولت صربيا ان تضم هذه الاجزاء من كوسوفو
بالقوه واعتقد ان هذه البعثه التابعه لحلف
شمال الاطلسيه هي التي تحول دون ضم صربيا
لهذه الاجزاء كما فعلت روسيا في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا جورجيو فروشيوني
الكاتب المختص فيه الشؤون الشؤون البلقان
في المعهد الايطاليه للدراسات الاساسيه
والدوليه ضيفنا من روما
[موسيقى]
مثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
امام محكمه الفينيورك بتهمه الاحتيال
والتضليل بشان ثروته وقالت المدعيه العامه
في نيويورك وهي ديمقراطيه ان ترامب
والمتهمين الاخرين ارتكبوا عمليات احتيال
متواصله ومتكرره
الاخرون ارتكبوا عمليات احتيال متواصله
ومتكرره اثبتنا ذلك في الاسبوع الماضي
وسنثبت ادعاءاتنا مره اخرى رساله بسيطه
بغض النظر عن مدى قوتك وعن مقدار الاموال
التي تعتقد انك تمتلكها لا احد فوق
القانون ومن مسؤوليه وواجبي تنفيذ ذلك
اليوم سنثبت قضيتنا في المحكمه
فقال ان الهدف من هذه القضايا التي تم
تحريكها ضده امام القضاء هو منعه من خوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه واضاف عقب مثوله امام
المحكمه ان بيانات ثروته لا تشوبها شائبه
وانه لم يتم ارتكابه اي جريمه
لو لم اكن في طليعه استطلاعات الراي ولم
اترشح للانتخابات لما وجهه الي هذه
الاتهامات ما يحصل في بلادنا امر شنيع
ويجب ان نوقفه اعتقد ان اغلبكم يفهم ما
يحصل الناخبون يفهمون ذلك وهذا هو الاهم
يرون انه بعد كل لائحه اتهام توجه الي
يرتفع رصيدي هناك عدد كبير من الشركات
والمؤسسات تغادر نيويورك لان المدعين
العامين والقضاه فاسدون تفضل شركات التوجه
الى اماكن اخرى حيث تعامل بشكل منصف وعادل
وفي العرض التالي نسلط الضوء على تفاصيله
هذه القضيه الجديده التي بدات فيها محاكمه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بقاضي واحد ودون محلفين يمثل امام محكمه
مدنيه في نيويورك الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب القضيه مدنيه هذه المره
ويتهم فيها ترامب بالاحتيال والتضليل بشان
ثروته فما القصه المدعيه العامه في
نيويورك
بين عامي 2011 و21 لتضخيم قيمه اصول
مجموعته التي تضم شركات متنوعه تشمل
عقارات وفنادق ونوادي جولف وغيرها خلال
تحقيق استمر ثلاث سنوات وجدت المدعيه
العامه ان ترامب وولديه
بالغوا في قيمه ثلاثه وعشرين من الاصول
الماليه والعقاريه لمجموعتهم للحصول على
قروض بشروط افضل وفق القاضي ارثر انجورون
الذي سينظر في القضيه يتهم ترامب وولداه
بتضخيم قيمه اصولهم بما بين 812 مليونا
الى اكثر من دولار بين 2014
و21
امر القاضي انجون بسحب تراخيص اعمال
تجاريه في نيويورك من ترامب ونجليه اضافه
الى مصادره الشركات المستهدفه في القضيه
كما تسعى المدعيه جيمس لتغريم الرئيس
السابق 250 مليون دولار على الاقل وفرض
حظر دائم عليه وعلى نجليه يمنعهم من اداره
اعمالهم في نيويورك وحظر لخمس سنوات على
الانشطه التجاريه والعقاريه لترامب
ومجموعته تضم المجموعه 500 كيان للاعمال
والاستثمار من ابرزها برج ترامب الذي
سيدخل في القضيه حيث يشتبه وفق الادعاء ان
الرئيس الامريكي السابقه بالغ في قيمته من
200 الى 300 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
ونتابع الان صورا للرئيس الامريكي السابق
صور من نيويورك في الواقع
لمجريات ما يجري في هذه المحاكمه التي
يحاكم فيها الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بتهمي الاحتيال وتضخيم ثروته علينا
الاحوال ينضم الينا من ميامي الدكتور
جلوبري كوجر استاذ القانون العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه ميامي الدكتور جريجوري
اهلا وسهلا بك ما هو السياسي وما هو
القانوني في هذه المحاكمه
الجزء القانوني هو ذاك المرتبط بمنظمه
ترامب التي تقادى كجزء من قضيه مدنيه بشان
الاحتيال والتضليل وكما اشرتم تضخيم قيمه
الاصول الخاصه بها وهذه الاصول ما كانت
بالمستوى المذكور هذا هو الجزء القانوني
اما بالنسبه الى الجزء السياسي هذه القضيه
تحاول ان تضع حدا لصوره التي بناها لنفسه
كرجل اعمال ناجح وكبير وطبعا لديه العلامه
التجاريه الخاصه به ترامب المعروفه لان
هذه القضيه تسلط الضوء عليه شخصيا وعلى
شركته على انه محتال وان كل هذه الصوره
غير صحيحه
وعمليه الاحتيال هذه اذا ما اثبت انها تمت
قد يتعين على دونالد ترامب ان يبيع عددا
كبيرا من اصوله بما في ذلك برج ترامب
الشهير في مدينه نيويورك وبالتالي هذه
الصفحه كبيره
للسمعه السياسيه لدونالد ترامب والسمعه
الماليه ايضا وربما هذا هو المؤلم اكثر
بالنسبه للرئيس السابق لانه اذا كان
سيتنازل عن كثير من
الشيء يعتبرها جزء من علامات التجاريه الى
اي مدى ستؤثر عليه هذه الصفقه عليه كرجل
اعمال هذه القضيه
رجل اعمال التاثير كبيرا للغايه على
الارجح سوف تضع هذه القضيه حدا لقدرته على
القيام بالاعمال في مدينه نيويورك نتحدث
عن غرامات ايضا
بكميات باهضه من الاموال وعلى الارجح لن
يتمكن من دفعها وسوف يعلن الافلاس
الشخصي في هذه المره نعم كما اشرتم بالفعل
هي صفعه ماليه قصوى وكبرى
لعلامته التجاريه
لشخصه هو يعتمد على علامته التجاريه ويصوق
لنفسه من خلال عمليته او علامته التجاريه
وكيف سيؤثر ذلك على فرص
دخوله الانتخابات لا ننسى انه خسر
الانتخابات الماضيه نعم لكن اكثر مرشح في
التاريخ حصل على اصوات
اكثر مرشح خاسر في التاريخ يحصل على يحصل
على صدف الانتخابات الماضيه وهذا يعني انا
قاعدته ان لم تزيد فهي لا تقل
نعم
طبعا
على الارجح قد لا يؤثر ذلك وهنا المفارقه
على حصوله على
تسميه الحزب الجمهوري
للترشح طبعا نتحدث عن عام سيء جدا على
المستوى الجنائي وعلى المستوى المدني من
حيث القضايا التي رفعت واتهم التي وجهت
تجاه ترامب ولكن
الجمهوريين لم يردعهم كل ذلك وطبعا هو
يحظى كما اشرتم بدعما عارم على العكس يبدو
ان هذه التهم ساعدته على المستوى السياسي
لكي يقول للناس
ولجمهوره انه يتعرض لمضايقات غير عادله
ومضايقات سياسيه لانه صوت الشعب الامريكي
وبالتالي داعموا الرئيس ترام ب تحلقوا من
حوله بالرهمي من هذه القضايا وبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان هذه القضيه او القضايا الاخرى من
شانها ان تؤثر على ترشحه ولكن طبعا هي سوف
تؤثر سلبا على سمعته بشكل عام شكرا جزيلا
لك من ميامي الدكتور
سد القانون السياسيه في جامعه ميامي
[موسيقى]
انا الرئيس المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي
عزمه الترشح لفتره ثالثه وذلك في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره في ديسمبر
المقبل واضاف الرئيس المصري في كلمه له
امام مؤتمر بالعاصمه الاداريه الجديده شرق
القاهره انه عقد العزم على استكمال الحلم
والترشح لفتره رئاسيه جديده وتاتي هذه
الخطوه التي كانت متوقعه على نطاق واسع في
ظل التعديلات الدستوريه التي اجريت قبل
اربع سنوات وتسمح للرئيس السيسي بالبقاء
في السلطه حتى عام 2030
قالت هيئه الدفاع عن الموقفين السياسيين
في تونس ان المعتقلين قرروا مقاطعه قاضي
التحقيق وكل اجراءاته واضافت الهيئه في
بيان ان المعتقلين يرفضون ان يكونوا جزءا
مما وصفتها بالمسرحيه القضائيه التي يراد
منها الجام المعارضه وعبر التلقيت القوه
الديمقراطيه التقدميه عن تضامنها مع
القياديه بجبهه الخلاص الوطني جوهر بمبارك
وبقيه المعتقلين السياسيين الذين اضطروا
الى الدخول في اضراب عن الطعام وتعريض
صحتهم للخطر وطالبت التنسيقيه في بيان
باطلاق سراحهم معتبره ان مواصله اعتقال
بالمبارك ورفاقه دون وجود ادله تثبت التهم
الموجهه اليهم هو احتجاز قصري ولا يعدو ان
يكون عمليه تصفيه حسابات سياسيه
اعلن الاتحاد الاسيوي لكره القدم الغاء
مباراه سفهان الايراني والاتحاد السعودي
في دوري ابطال اسيا بسبب ما سماها ظروفا
غير متوقعه وقال ان هذا الامر سيحال الى
اللجان المختصه وقد رفض لاعب الفريق
السعودي مغادره غرفه تغيير الملابس بسبب
وضع مجسم للجنرال الايرانيه الراحل قاسم
سليماني عندما مدخل الملعب وقالت وكاله
فارس الايرانيه ان ما سمتها بالمزاعم بان
الانسحاب كان بسبب وجود مجسم للقائد
السابق لفريق القدس بالحرس الثوري قاسم
سليماني هي مزاعم واهيه حسب تعبيرها
واضافت ان الفريق تدرب امس في الملعب ذاته
رغم المجسم الموجود هناك منذ سنوات ومن
جهه قال مدير فريق سباحه
سيقدم شكوى رسميه ضد الفريق السعودي لدى
الاتحاد الاسيوي لكره القدم معتبرا ان
تصرف الفريق السعودي يتناقض مع الاعراف
الرياضيه حسب تعبيره وفي المقابل افادت
وسائل الاعلام السعوديه بان لاعبي فريق
اتحاد جده رفضوا النزول الى ارضيه الملعب
ملعب اصفهان اعتراضا على ممارسات النادي
الايراني بوضع الصور وتماثيل بعيده عن
مجال الرياضه
[موسيقى]
افتتح امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثري معرض اكسبو الدوحه 2023 الذي يحمل
شعار صحراء وخضراء بيئه افضل ويستمر حتى
28 من مارس اذار المقبل هذا المعرض يرمي
لتعزيز الابتكارات المستدامه ومكافحه
التصحر ويتضمن فعاليات ورشات عمل للبحث عن
حلول لمشكلات التصحر والتغير المناخي
وتحيه تحديات الاستدامه
صحراء خضراء بيئه افضل بهذه الرؤيه دشنت
دوله قطر المعرضه الدوليه الاول من نوعه
في قطر والمنطقه معركه اكسبو الدوحه 2023
على امتداد اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون متر
مربع من المساحات الخضراء وتحديدا حديقه
البدع في قلب الدوحه اكثر من ثمانين دوله
ومنظمه دوليه ومحليه تشارك في المعرض على
مدى 179 يوما خلال الافتتاح حرس الرئيس
مجلس الوزراء القطري وزير الخارجيه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني على تاكيد ان
النسخه الحاليه من المعرض جاءت لتكون دعوه
للقيام بمبادرات وشراكات جاده من اجل عالم
بيئي متوازن وان فعاليات معرض اكسبو
الدوحه 2023 هي جزء من المبادرات التي
تتبناها قطر في اطار رؤيتها الوطنيه
2030 اليوم تتشرف الدوحه مجددا
ايضا حدث عالمي ينسجم مع التزامات قطر في
التنميه المستدامه وطنيا ودوليا
ويشكل اضافه نوعيه للمبادرات المتنوعه
التي تتبناها قطر لضمان مستقبل اكثر امانا
واستقرارا لشعوب الارض كافه
سته المقبله سيستقطب المعرض نحو ثلاثه
ملايين زائر ليكونوا شركاء في ايجاد مزيد
من الحلول الصديقه للبيئه في مختلف نواحي
الحياه من خلال ورشات عمل لاتاحه الوسائل
لتحقيق اهداف والدوحه للتزامن مع وتيره
التغيرات البيئيه المتسارعه ياتي
2023 ليكون خلال الاشهر القادمه من خلال
التعاون الدولي بدايه لايجاد حلول
للتحديات البيئيه وابرز قضاياها الامن
الغذائي والتغير المناخي وتحقيق الاهداف
العالميه لتنميه مستدامه صار رشيد الجزيره
الدوحه
[موسيقى]
نقطه توتر في القاره الافريقيه نسلط عليها
الضوء في فقره المتابعه هذه الليله
والحديث هنا عن مالي وازماتها مع الجماعات
المسلحه فما الجديد في هذه المواجهه قبل
ساعات توجه رتل كبير من الجيش المالي من
جاو الى منطقه كذا الاستراتيجيه التي تعد
معقله للطوارق في شمال مالي خلال هي منطقه
استراتيجيه بين مالي والجزائر كما نشاهد
على الخارطه وتبعد اكثر من 1500 كيلو متر
عن العاصمه باماكو ومئات الكيلومترات من
مدينتي جاو وتمبكتو الرئيسيه في الشمال
هذا التوتر يتزامن مع تواصل انسحاب بعثه
حفظ السلام التابعه للامم المتحده
والمعروفه اختصارا باسم مينوسما تنفيذا
لطلب من المجلس العسكري الحاكم بدات
البعثه بالفعل تسليمه معسكراتها الى
السلطات الماليه هذا اغضب المسلحين الذين
يرون ان مراكز الامم المتحده في الشمال
يجب ان تعود اليهم بموجب اتفاقات سابقه
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنا من نواكشوط
العقيد البخاري محمد مؤمل الخبير في
القضايا الامنيه والاستراتيجيه بمنطقه
الساحل
اهلا وسهلا بك العقيد مؤمل
تعلق بهذا الانتشار للجيش المالي ما فرصه
جيش مالي في وضعه الحالي في استعاده
السيطره على هذه المنطقه منطقه الطوارئ
بالشمال
الحقيقه الوضع صعب جدا بالنسبه للدوله
الماليه بشكل عام وخاصه بالنسبه لقوته
المسلحه
فشعرهم الذي يحملون منذ فتره هو استعاده
السياده الوطنيه على مالي سياسيا وميدانيا
للارض وذلك
يرونه من خلال زاويته الزاويه الاولى
ولعبوا على
وترة الروح الوطنيه للمواطنين هو اخراج
القوات الاجنبيه وخاصه القوات الفرنسيه
ومن بعدها قوات الامم المتحده علميه
ويعتبرون اخراجها من الارض الماليه جزء من
السياده سيادتهم على الارض ضمان سياده
الجزء الثاني هو استرجاع سلطه الدوله على
جميع التراب المالي وهذه المنطقه كما
ذكرتم في مقدمتكم منطقه كدال وضواحيها
كانت خارجه عن سيطره السلطات الماليه منذ
2013 او 2014 وقعت تحت سيطره ما يوصف هذه
وبعد انسحابهم على اثر تدخل عمليه سربال
وقعت تحت سيطره سربال من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
الحركات حركات الطوارئ وهنالك كان اتفاق
ضمني ولو انه لم يعلن عنه بين القوات
الفرنسيه من جهه وقوات الطوارئ وكذلك ايضا
مع المنسمان لما بدات المجلس ما تنسحب
طلبت منها بل
حاولت ان تفرض ذلك السلطات الحاكمه في
مالي ان تسلمها تلك المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها القوات الطوارق
المستقلين المنسيقيه
اخر مره حاول الجيش المالي استعاده
السيطره على هذه المنطقه
كبيره ما المتوقع الان هل جد جديد يغير
هذه المعادله
هو هو مع الاسف كل يوم يتعرض لازائم كبيره
وخاصه منذ شهر شهر الماضي على عيد الطوارق
ومن قبلهم وموازاه معهم ايضا على ايدي
الجماعات الجهاديه التي تنحصر اساسا
بجماعتين رئيسيتين داعش والقاعده وما يعرف
بانصار الاسلام الان ارسلوا قوه كبيره جدا
قوامها حوالي اردت القوامه حوالي 120
سياره بالضبط حسب الاعلام 119 ولكن متى
ستصل وكيف الراتل العسكري حرك كلما كبر
كلما كانت حركته عويصه شكرا يتطلب تامينا
من الامامي ومن الخلف ومن فوق ومن الاطراف
شكرا لك
يعني صعبه كما يبدو شكرا جزيلا العقيد
البخاري محمد مؤمل الخبير في القضايا
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه بمنطقه الساحل شكرا
جزيلا لك
بالعلم والمال يا ابن الناس مجده لم يبنى
مجد على جهد واقلال الاحتفاء بالعلم
والعلماء امر ضروري لتنميه وبناء
المجتمعات ولا تقوم نهضه في اي امه الا
عبر امور من اهمها الاهتمام بالبحث العلمي
وتقدير العلماء فما الجديد الجديد انا
جائزه نوبل للطب منحت قبل ساعات للمجاريه
كاريكو ولا امريكي جو
وذلك عن اكتشافتهما بشان لقاح الحمض
النووي الريبوزي المرسال الام ار ان اي
التي كان لها دور اساسي في التوصل الى
اللقاحات المضاده لواء كوفي 19 اللجنه
التي تتولى اختبار الفائزين قالت ان
الفائزين ساهماه بوتيره لم يسبق لها مثيل
في التوصل الى لقاحات في خضم احد اكبر
التهديدات لصحه الانسان في العصر الحديث
وقد شكلت اللقاحات التي تعتمد تقنيه الحمض
النووي والريبوزي
التي ابرزتها ازمه كوفيد دروه ثوره علاجيه
وهي اكتشاف قد يستخدم ايضا لمحاربه بعض
انواع السرطان والامراض المعديه بعد عقود
من البحوث والنكسات المتعدده هذا نختم
[موسيقى]